[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
del cob y 19 a continuación nuestro
demarcó
hoy vamos a hablar de bolivia este país
va a las urnas en unas atípicas
elecciones presidenciales en medio del
avance del hobby 19 unas elecciones
cruciales para la situación política que
está viviendo este país en las que sin
duda alguna es la pandemia del cobi 19
tendrá un papel destacado tendrá
importancia vamos a conocer cómo está el
panorama y cuáles son las medidas de
bioseguridad que adoptó el gobierno para
que los bolivianos puedan ejercer su
derecho ciudadano
y también preocupación en chile por el
rebrote que toma cada vez más fuerza en
las regiones del sur del país las cifras
son desconcertantes y los médicos y
especialistas hablan de una nueva cepa
que está afectando particularmente a la
región de magallanes analizaremos el
tema para conocer qué es lo que está
sucediendo y cuáles son las causas de
este rápido rebrote en el sur de chile
y el mundo sigue a la espera de una
vacuna contra el kobe 19 algunas
farmacéuticas avanzan en sus estudios
otras esta semana anunciaron una pausa
debido a las complicaciones con algunos
de sus voluntarios vamos a conversar con
el doctor carlos pérez analista
científico y colaborador permanente de
france 24 para saber cuáles son los
avances en torno a las vacunas
comenzamos vamos entonces a bolivia allí
este país como ya lo decía lo decíamos
va a las urnas en medio de la pandemia
del cob y 19 pese a las dificultades que
ha vivido el país por el coronavirus han
hecho esta convocatoria a las urnas la
prioridad ahora es llevar estabilidad
política y también terminar la
interinidad del gobierno para que el
país ya se enrute para tener un frente
en torno a la lucha contra la pandemia y
la crisis social y la crisis económica
vamos a conversar con medio ibaka
nuestra corresponsal permanente en este
país ella se encuentra en la ciudad de
la paz
hola mary gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en kobe 19 la semana en américa y
cuáles son esas medidas
para el cuidado que ha instaurado el
gobierno para que por favor los
ciudadanos puedan ir pero pues
cuidándose
qué tal santiago un saludo para toda la
audiencia de france 24 el tribunal
supremo electoral ha establecido una
serie de medidas de bioseguridad para
que la gente vaya a votar protegida por
ejemplo todos los ciudadanos todos los
electores deben concurrir a las urnas
con barbijo de forma obligatoria deben
llevar su propio bolígrafo de tal manera
que no tengan que prestarse un bolígrafo
ya sea del jurado electoral o de quien
se encuentre en la mesa de sufragio y
debe mantener la distancia adecuada para
que no se produzca un contagio por otro
lado se ha dividido a los votantes en
dos grandes grupos los votantes cuyo
carné de identidad termina entre 0 y 4
deben votar por la mañana y el resto
deben votar por la tarde de tal manera
que no exista aglomeración por otro lado
se ha aumentado el tiempo de votación en
una hora antes las mesas de sufragio
terminaban o cerraban alrededor de las 4
de la tarde pero ahora van a cerrar a
las 5 de la tarde y por otro lado el
tribunal supremo electoral además ha
dispuesto la ampliación de los recintos
recintos de votación para que la gente
no se aglomere
los pocos recintos que antes estaban
previstos para esta votación y en
términos sanitarios cómo se encuentra
bolivia en este momento horas previas al
inicio de estos comicios
mira bolivia está en franca la curva
está en franca franca declinatoria de
hecho el último dato que tenemos es de
ayer con 178 casos confirmados de
coronavirus en el país pero muy distante
digamos a los más de 2000 casos que se
habían presentado en agosto cuando la
curva estaba en su pico más alto hasta
la fecha se han registrado casi 140 mil
casos de kobe 19 en el país más de 8000
muertos sin embargo existen informes en
base al número de fallecidos en esta
época de que indican que hay 20.000
fallecidos por encima del promedio que
se producía habitualmente en meses como
los que en los que se ha producido la
pandemia en todo caso debo comentarte
que las campañas electorales han sido
muy intensas y ha habido partidos
políticos que han generado
concentraciones masivas y no sólo eso
sino que el alto comisionado de naciones
unidas para los derechos humanos ha
establecido que se han producido al
menos 40 episodios de violencia en el
marco
de la campaña electoral todo eso ha
implicado concentración de miles de
personas en las calles del país lo que
hace temer que próximamente se produzca
una segunda ola o un rebrote de
coronavirus en el país y lo que tiene
obviamente preocupadas a las autoridades
peri y que hay de los bolivianos de los
votantes los ciudadanos como están hay
temor por ir a votar precisamente para
por la pandemia de kobe 19 hay temor por
creer que estas medidas que ha dictado
el gobierno no son suficientes por los
rebrotes que puedan haber en dos semanas
después de los comicios cuál es el
panorama en torno a los ciudadanos
obviamente el tema de la salud es una
preocupación muy grande entre los
ciudadanos bolivianos pero yo diría que
la preocupación mayor es la crisis
política y porque te lo digo porque la
gente está temerosa de que después de
las elecciones hay algún partido que no
quiera reconocer los resultados y en ese
caso se pueda generar violencia
nuevamente tal como ha ocurrido el año
pasado pese a eso yo creo que la gente
está dispuesta a ir a votar porque
considera que es necesario que el país
que analice toda esta polarización y
esta confrontación a través del voto a
través de la institucionalidad y no a
través de los hechos de violencia de
hecho te comento que hay algunos
estudios que hablan de la voluntad de la
gente de ir a votar la empresa mercados
y muestras ha hecho una encuesta
recientemente en la que se establece que
el 67 por ciento de los bolivianos
consultados considera que es muy seguro
ir a votar y sólo el 18 por ciento dice
que es poco seguro y un dato muy
interesante indica que los que mayor
temor tendrían de ir a votar son las
personas
y decidirían su voto por el ex
presidente carlos mesa mientras que las
personas que votarían por luís arse son
las personas que no tendrían ningún
miedo de ir a votar en todo caso el
domingo lo sabremos en qué nivel está el
ausentismo en bolivia y sabremos si es
que los bolivianos han preferido
resolver su crisis política y protegerse
para ir a votar en esta pandemia
la abstención va a ser un punto clave en
estos comicios del domingo mary muchas
gracias por este reporte desde la ciudad
de la paz y los ojos de américa latina
están en este país suramericano para ver
cómo se desarrollan estos comicios en
plena pandemia del cob el 19 vamos a
cambiar de tema cada vez son más los
estudios que evidencian que contagiarse
de kobe 19 no garantiza una inmunización
total hasta el momento han sido
registrados 25 casos de re inflexión en
el mundo entero el más reciente de ellos
en suecia también uno de ellos una
paciente de más de 80 años falleció tras
haber sido diagnosticada por segunda vez
con coronavirus esto sucedió en los
bajos veamos más detalles en el
siguiente informe
es la esperanza de cualquiera que tenga
la mala suerte de contraer kobe 19
desarrollar la inmunidad a cualquier
otra infección pero ahora hay más
evidencia de que contagiarse no es
sinónimo de inmunización según la
revista médica the lancet un joven de 25
años de nevada resultó positivo por
segunda vez después de presentar
síntomas dio positivo inicialmente el 18
de abril posteriormente yo negativo el
26 de mayo sin embargo sólo unos días
después el desarrolló síntomas más
intensos que incluyeron dolor de cabeza
fiebre y náuseas y dio positivo de nuevo
el 5 de junio no es la primera
reinfección documentada de los 37
millones de casos registrados en todo el
mundo 5 reinfecciones han sido
descubiertas en bélgica países bajos
hong kong y ecuador- sainz
hemos tenido cinco casos en todo el
mundo lo que obviamente es una pequeña
cantidad por supuesto es preocupante que
la re infecciones sea posible pero
debería preocuparse más por infectarse
en primer lugar en lugar de volver a
infectarse
tiene ficción la secuencia genética del
virus que infectó al hombre en nevada
mostró que fue infectado dos veces por
dos cepas diferentes de sars coptos
científicos dicen que aunque se necesita
más investigación los casos confirmados
de reinfección sólo han ocurrido en
pacientes que presentaban síntomas lo
que significa que las tasas de
infecciones podrían ser más altas pero
pasar desapercibidas entre aquellos que
son asintomáticos las recomendaciones
son tomar precauciones y seguir los
protocolos sanitarios a lo largo de las
últimas semanas hemos hecho seguimiento
a la apertura social que ha tenido lugar
en chile en este país las cifras de
contagio se han ido reduciendo levemente
en los últimos días pero las en regiones
del sur del país es decir la región de
aysén de los lagos de los ríos araucanía
y magallanes allí están presentando una
situación un poco más crítica a los
números de los casos siguen en aumento
vamos a conocer más detalles de lo que
está sucediendo en este país
suramericano con el doctor juan carlos
experto guió el es médico cirujano
también es especialista en medicina
interna
logía es el director titular del
hospital base de la ciudad de valdivia y
gracias señor doctor bertolo por estar
con nosotros aquí en france24 y qué
explicación puede haber para este
rebrote que está teniendo lugar en
particular en las regiones del sur y
llama sobretodo la atención lo que
sucede en la región de magallanes
muy buenas noches muchas gracias por
conocer nuestra versión desde el
servicio sanitario y nuestra red de
salud regional le puedo explicar que en
realidad esto coincide con una apertura
del confinamiento previo que había en
estas regiones en la estación invernal y
ahora viene una apertura de primavera y
coincidió con la reactivación económica
que se hizo o que se abrió para
facilitar la recuperación laboral la
recuperación económica de la región y
evidentemente eso conlleva a
desplazamiento de personas de mayor
riesgo de contactos y obviamente un
incremento nosotros en la región de los
ríos por ejemplo no habíamos tenido
prácticamente un brote habíamos tenido
casos muy esporádicos una cantidad por
400 mil habitantes bajísimas de
infectado no llegábamos a los 800
infectados
en seis meses con una tasa bajísima de
fallecidos teníamos ocho fallecidos en
seis meses
y de repente se abrió el confinamiento
se abrió la actividad sobre todo son
regiones que dependen del touring con
mucho y es uno de los componentes
principales de la actividad económica es
el turismo y evidentemente eso conlleva
un movimiento de personas desplazamiento
de personas y eso ha ocasionado en gran
medida que tengamos una mayor incidencia
de casos en el caso de la región de los
ríos hemos regresado a una fase 2 para
poder controlar este que no es un
rebrote para nosotros sino que vienen
siendo un primer brote muy tardío en
relación a la pandemia si el doctor bert
oglio también se habla y se ha
especulado un poco sobre una posible
mutación del virus en estas regiones
como usted lo decía por algunos factores
externos particularmente estas regiones
del sur de chile tienen un clima mucho
más frío que el resto del país
prácticamente el verano dura solamente
unas pocas semanas y las temperaturas no
son muy altas tienen unos
en muy particulares y también la forma
de vida es muy particular por las
condiciones que hay allí tendría algo
que ver este factor climático y se
estaría hablando de una posible mutación
sí bueno en una epidemia son tres
factores los que debemos considerar o
cuatro al menos como componentes
determinantes del comportamiento de la
epidemia el primero es la característica
del agente infectante en este caso un
virus de transmisión respiratoria de
transmisión aérea en segundo término las
características sociodemográficas
geográficas climáticas y también
epidemiológica que se derivan de cada
lugar o cada región y en tercer lugar la
etnia del lugar donde las
características genéticas de la
población también determinan un modo de
respuesta inmunitaria particular a esa
estructura genética para eso estamos
estudiando en chile en este momento en
tres regiones o áreas regionales del
país en la región norte que es la región
desértica y de clima cálido y seco en la
región central que es la región
mediterránea el chile central que tiene
va a ser la región metropolitana la
ciudad de capital y luego la zona sur
austral que es región subantártica de
selva fría lluviosa con un rango de
temperaturas promedio en el invierno de
810 grados celsius y en el verano de
unos 22 23 grados
en esta región particularmente en la
ciudad extrema de puntarenas en
magallanes ha habido una particular
cantidad de pacientes y la
transmisibilidad y el alto número de
pacientes en esa ciudad en esa región
magallánica ha hecho pensar que el virus
podría ser diferente y que podría ser
otra cepa más infectante y que tenga
mayor prevalencia en este tipo de clima
particularmente esta es una zona donde
hay mucho viento
hay una densidad poblacional urbana es
extensa en territorio pero la población
urbana es densa por las mismas
características
del clima y entonces podemos pensar que
podría haber una cepa diferente entonces
se para estudiar este fenómeno sean
conectados muestras de la región sur
austral de la región mediterránea
central y de la región norte tanto de
virus nuestras con el virus como de
características genéticas de los
pacientes que han sufrido una enfermedad
estamos haciendo un análisis de las tres
variables las características
sociodemográficas y geográficas de cada
región
luego las características del virus el
genoma viral y luego la genética de la
población que ha sufrido la infección
qué factor si es el virus propiamente
tal tiene la característica genética de
la población o es la condición socio
demográfica y geográfica del lugar y el
clima por supuesto sí doctor que está
determinando que haya diferencias entre
una región y otra en la prevalencia y la
incidencia de la infección muchos
factores a tener en cuenta doctor ya
para terminar usted ya lo decía son
regiones que viven del turismo es la
industria más importante magallanes
sobre todo tiene una industria
importante para los meses de verano que
ya están prácticamente a la vuelta de la
esquina qué puede esperar entonces el
resto del país ahora que han reiniciado
los vuelos que están en la apertura
social y económica podemos estar viendo
a chile en un rebrote similar que está
viviendo el sur ahora extendiéndose de
norte a sur
es curioso porque el sur se había
mantenido durante el invierno muy bien y
con una con una infección muy controlada
mientras que en el norte había sido
mucho más severa ahora en el norte la
infección ha disminuido enormemente está
bastante controlada de hecho casi no hay
comunas en confinamiento y hemos estado
presenciando un rebrote en el sur la
onda se ha desplazado hacia el sur ahora
yo creo que esto tiene que ver mucho con
las condiciones climáticas y con los
movimientos de personas por es
justamente la actividad económica ahora
estamos volviendo a controlar por partes
por áreas por comunas y poniéndolas en
distintas fases según la prevalencia y
la incidencia de la infección
de esta manera ir controlando y agotando
el fenómeno en todo caso
esta red hospitalaria en nuestra
infraestructura de salud todavía no se
ve superada mayan 60 un 70 por ciento de
ocupación entonces todavía tenemos
afortunadamente capacidad instalada de
hospitales de cuidado intensivo de
ventiladores para un margen todavía de
seguridad el doctor alberto vio gracias
por estar con nosotros aquí en france 24
explicarnos este panorama particular que
se está presentando en estas cuatro o
cinco regiones del sur de chile el
doctor bert oglio desde la ciudad de
valdivia en la región de los ríos en el
sur de chile vamos a continuar con otros
temas también fue destacado esta semana
la noticia en torno a la senadora y
también candidata a la vicepresidencia
de eeuu kamala harris que canceló dos
eventos electorales debido a que varios
integrantes de su campaña dieron
positivo por hobby 19 los eventos
estaban previstos en asheville y en
charlotte en el estado de carolina del
norte y fueron cancelados a la brevedad
posible' después de confirmar que
pruebas practicadas dieron positivo
harris indicó que no había estado en
contacto cercano con estas personas los
días previos y se sometió a una prueba
que posteriormente arrojaría un
resultado negativo
y en venezuela el registro de decesos de
trabajadores de la salud llega ya al 30%
de la cifra total de las personas
fallecidas por cuenta del cob y 19 la
ayuda humanitaria que recibe este país
suramericano no es suficiente y el
gobierno de nicolás maduro tampoco puede
garantizar el material adecuado para la
bioseguridad ante esta falta de
suministros los mismos empleados de la
salud tomaron cartas en el asunto veamos
a vivir rodríguez es una enfermera que
atiende en primera línea de los
pacientes con kobe 19 y para trabajar
solo reciben un par de guantes y un
tapabocas al día ya se contagió de
coronavirus pero tuvo más suerte que
otros de sus colegas quienes pasaron a
engrosar la lista de fallecidos en
venezuela esto viene sucediendo hace
muchísimos años esto no es de ahorita
por la pandemia en el estado tiene
tiempo que que no surte a los hospitales
ni en cuanto a los métodos barrera ni a
medicinas diversas organizaciones
ligadas al sector sanitario denuncia
ante el 95% de los trabajadores en los
hospitales públicos no cuentan con todo
el equipo de protección y bioseguridad
si la cifra de sanitarios muertos
porcentualmente sería la más alta del
mundo pero los trabajadores sanitarios
como se le dicen al mundo
parecemos los astronautas totalmente
protegidos en el caso de nuestros
trabajadores no tienen la indumentaria
necesaria o se cumplen con las
exigencias que señala con mucha claridad
la organización mundial de la salud
ante la imposibilidad del gobierno de
poder dotar los hospitales con material
de seguridad el gremio sindical
organizado a los trabajadores sanitarios
para que ellos mismos fabriquen sus
tapabocas cosen unos 300 al día para
repartir entre sus colegas es un acto de
apoyo pero también de frustración se
siente frustrante tener que sacar de
nuestro propio bolsillo para poder hacer
esto
cuando quien nos tiene que cuidar es el
propio gobierno
porque cuidar a un país no es solamente
hablar según cifras de la federación
venezolana médica el 30 por ciento de
los muertos por kobe 19 en el país son
trabajadores del sector salud en total
son más de 200 los sanitarios que han
fallecido y se estima que estos números
sigan creciendo mientras el gobierno
continúe sin garantizar los insumos
necesarios para trabajar
herminio fernández france24 caracas
y ahora demos un vistazo al avance de
las vacunas que están siendo
desarrolladas para combatir el kobe y 19
fue noticia precisamente esta semana el
anuncio de johnson y johnson que indicó
que pondrá en pausa su investigación por
una enfermedad inexplicable en algunos
de sus voluntarios vamos a conversar
entonces con el doctor carlos pérez él
es médico infectólogo y también es
asesor científico de france 24 en la
cara ya conocida aquí en el canal de
ustedes ya lo han visto varias veces en
nuestros programas doctor pérez gracias
por estar con nosotros y comienzo por
preguntarle esta suspensión o pausa de
la investigación que estaba
desarrollando johnson y johnson como
recibir esta noticia como algo negativo
o como algo positivo que indica que el
procedimiento está siendo tomado con las
precauciones debidas
si lo importante en las vacunas es la
seguridad y la seguridad se establece a
través de fases clínicas y evaluación de
cada uno de estos procesos y el hecho de
que haya sucedido esta pausa no es ni
bueno ni malo es lo que a lo que estamos
sometidos cuando hacemos un ensayo
clínico que se hace en este caso se
evalúa ese enfermo y una persona un
grupo de profesionales que no hacen
parte del estudio vacunas son
completamente independientes evalúan qué
sucedió con esa persona si esa persona
tuvo una reacción por la vacuna o si fue
un hecho coincidencial este enfermo de
otra cosa tenía otra enfermedad y una
vez se saque un dictamen y digan no fue
atribuirle la vacuna sigue el estudio si
se considera que es atraerla atribuirle
a la vacuna se estudian todos los
sujetos del estudio para evaluar qué
tipo de reacciones hay
doctor hay mucha expectativa en torno a
las vacunas el mundo entero está
siguiendo el paso a paso de estas
investigaciones pero estas vacunas una
vez sean aprobadas y empiecen a ser
distribuidas no nos va a devolver la
vida que teníamos antes de la pandemia
de la noche a la mañana esto también
tomará tiempo
llevar y garantizar que la gente reciba
estas dosis para empezar a hacerle
frente a la corona virus cómo empezar a
manejar esta situación a nivel emocional
que así salga una vacuna a final de año
no va a ser inmediata la llegada de
estas a todos los países del mundo
soy muy importante porque la vacuna es
una victoria efímera si la vemos a corto
plazo
las vacunas tienen una fase que la
producción la seguridad y después viene
la más compleja de la implementación y
la accesibilidad que significa es que
carla noticia más esperada del mundo es
que una vacuna funciona pero una verdad
con unas funciones que tienen que poner
a producir a producir una gran cantidad
eso excepto montiel y una vez se
distribuyese hacer la accesibilidad las
cadenas de frío y las de instituciones
en el mundo etcétera etcétera y al menos
lo que conocemos en la mayoría vacunas
son dos dosis es decir que una persona
recibe una dosis no quiere que ya
inmediatamente no le da coronavirus de
recibir una segunda dosis y un tiempo
prudencial después de la segunda dosis
la persona tendrá la inmunidad eso que
asegura que por lo menos serían dos o
tres meses para iniciar el proceso de
vacunación hay inmunidad por eso y lo
más sensato es pensar que durante el
2021 y tal vez en el segundo semestre al
estarán
implementación de la vacuna mientras en
este año se hacen los estudios de
seguridad de la vacuna el gran reto va a
ser accesibilidad para todos los humanos
doctor y hay otro punto importante de la
efectividad que pueda tener esa posible
vacuna no estamos seguros que vaya a ser
100% garantizado que nos blinde contra
el coronavirus por decirlo de alguna
manera puede que sea simplemente un 60
por ciento un 40 por ciento un 70 por
ciento por ejemplo la del sarampión
solamente cubre un 98 por ciento que es
alto pero tomo mucho llegar a eso
esto también entonces representa tiempo
también tenemos que tener en cuenta este
factor
sonaría que la mejor vacuna hasta hoy es
el tapabocas porque nosotros tenemos
estas medidas de precaución de etiqueta
social de higiene que tenemos van a
persistir un largo tiempo y yo creo que
en algunas de ellas es
significativamente bueno pero ese es
también el gran reto en los virus
respiratorios las vacunas que ya
conocemos como vacunas de la influenza
llegan a un 60 o 70 por ciento de
efectividad es probable que estas
vacunas de corona ellos tengan esa
efectividad ahora eso no quiere decir
que no todo el mundo
se vaya a poder inmunizar completamente
lo que muy probablemente sucede es que
se requiere que un gran número de
personas estén vacunas para que haya la
famosa inmunidad de rebaño es lograr es
vacunar mente no con inmunidad natural
como se pretende
y esperar también revacunaciones pero
estamos ante otro reto por ejemplo lo
que hablábamos ahorita si el virus ha
mutado será que la vacuna que
desarrollamos por un virus servirá para
otros virus también cada cuanto hay que
vacunar porque ya está en mundos
habitados de inflexión entonces la
vacuna será cada seis meses cada año
pues son varios los que doctor usted lo
mencionaba la inmunidad del rebaño
precisamente esta semana la o ms criticó
esta práctica que fue una de las normas
que aplicó suecia y también islandés
simplemente dejó que el virus circulará
de forma libre por todo el país pero
ante la demora de una vacuna ésta puede
ser una posibilidad sobre todo viendo lo
que está pasando en europa con este
rebrote y también viendo que en
suramérica las cifras empiezan a
retroceder un poco el escenario no es
más fácil armar este rompecabezas
definitivamente el libro de cómo atender
una pandemia no lo hemos escrito estamos
pidiendo cada uno con hojas con lágrimas
qué es la inmunidad de rebaño de limón y
de rebaño creo que un gran don de 60 y
70 por ciento de la población se infecta
para que el otro 30% que no sea
infectado nos infectó el problema esto
es que no sabemos cuánto ahora la
inmunidad por ejemplo en enfermedades
que produce inmunidad para el largo
tiempo probablemente de media de años
sirva para algo
hepatitis a cosas así pero no para esta
enfermedad que no sabemos cuánto dura la
inmunidad ni qué tipo de mundial
funciona y si el virus está mutando por
eso cuando habla de efecto de relaño por
inmunidad natural es que la gente salga
a infectarse no es porque moriría
demasiada gente y no sabríamos si
realmente es una estrategia exitosa no
es un buen llamado la única forma
inmunidad rebaño es acompañar la
inmunidad vacunal es decir a través de
una vacuna con las medidas de precaución
y que pase el tiempo para que todos nos
pudiéramos inmunizar en el tiempo de
esto es algo de paciencia de resiliencia
y de mucha esperanza pero no es una
solución fácil y seguimos esperando
doctor entonces cómo se desarrolla esta
pandemia cómo se desarrolla
y como avanza el rebrote en europa esto
parece que fueron de javu porque le
estoy haciendo preguntas que llevamos
siete meses dándole vueltas pero es que
la pandemia sigue y el rebrote en europa
nos dice que no hemos pasado esta
primera página sobre todo aquí en
américa latina' muchas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros aquí en kobe 19 la
semana en américa haber explicado este
tema para nosotros
en nuestra sección en redes veamos otros
temas que fueron destacados y que fueron
noticia a lo largo de la semana
comenzamos con esta publicación del
diario del diario el país de españa la
oms se confirma que ni la cloroquina ni
el rem de civil ni otros dos
tratamientos salvan vidas esa es la
conclusión a la que llegó el ensayo
solidarity del organismo de las naciones
unidas que afirma que ninguno de estos
fármacos contra el kobe 19 que estaba
siendo probado reduce la mortalidad del
virus a su turno también lado ms indicó
que estos fármacos usados para otras
dolencias fueron utilizados por los
médicos en su urgencia por mitigar el
avance del virus del cobi 19 en los
pacientes pero ninguno demostró tener
efectos significativos en la reducción
de la mortalidad
y esta publicación es de francia 24
punto com porque algunos científicos
describen la crisis del coronavirus como
una sin demia la controversia llega
meses después de que la oms cuando en
marzo pasado decretó esta emergencia
como una pandemia pero que por sus
incidencias en otros sectores más
vulnerables de la sociedad debe ser
tratada como una endemia debido a que
refleja además una amplia interacción de
factores sociales y también biológicos
ya lo veíamos en el caso de magallanes
en chile- el término todavía no es
aceptado por la real academia española
de la lengua pero la fundación español
urgente acepta este término que es una
traducción de un anglicismo saint de
mick porque esta crisis refleja como ya
lo decíamos una sinergia entre varias
patologías que tienen factores sociales
y coexisten en un tiempo y lugar
determinado
y también lo mencionamos a lo largo de
este programa el anuncio de la
farmacéutica johnson y johnson que
anunció que tuvo lugar el anuncio tuvo
lugar este inicio de la semana y tiene
que ver con la suspensión de los ensayos
clínicos de su potencial vacuna contra
el coronavirus debido a que algunos de
los voluntarios de su estudio
presentaron una inexplicable enfermedad
la compañía no indicó cuánto o cuándo
retomará su investigación debido a que
tiene que determinar la naturaleza de
esta dolencia y esto le puede llevar
varios días semanas e incluso meses
y la ciudad ancestral inca de machu
picchu un importante atractivo turístico
para perú abrió sus puertas nuevamente
espero solamente para un turista japonés
que estaba en este país suramericano
desde hacía 7 meses completamente varado
allí debido a las restricciones que
impuso el gobierno por la pandemia del
cubil 19 la historia a continuación
el sueño de 10 y está acá llama de
recorrer las ruinas de machu picchu se
cumplió este turista japonés que
permaneció atrapado por la pandemia en
perú durante siete meses logró a conocer
este paraje ancestral con un permiso
especial de las autoridades y se
convirtió en el primero en visitarlo
tras el levantamiento de las
restricciones por la emergencia
sanitaria tu sur este tour es realmente
asombroso gracias por dejarme ver esto
aunque la propagación del brote de kobe
19 impidió que usara el pase que había
comprado para entrar en marzo a la
ciudad inca nada pudo impedir que su
estadía en una localidad en las faldas
de las montañas cercanas a este antiguo
poblado andino terminará con su ascenso
al santuario que según cifras oficiales
fue visitado por más de un millón de
turistas internacionales en 2019 pero no
japonés ha ingresado junto con nuestro
jefe de parque el impacto de la pandemia
en territorio peruano afectó a decenas
de ciudadanos que como takayama no
pudieron retornar a sus lugares de
origen debido al cierre de fronteras en
la nación que tiene la mayor tasa de
por cada 100.000 habitantes de acuerdo
con datos de la universidad johns
hopkins
y así llegamos al final de este resumen
de kobe 19 la semana en américa ustedes
pueden seguir conectados con la
programación de france 24 más
información también en la página web en
las redes sociales y en la app
nosotros nos volvemos a encontrar dentro
de 8 días con otro resumen con más
noticias aquí en el programa feliz fin
de semana
[Música]